okay that does not mean that this is a
start to some other hi everyone it's
Charlie this is gonna be my Avengers
endgame post-credit scene for the
spider-man scene from the big rereleased
there was all this extra footage that
they tacked on to the end of Avengers
endgame screenings all over the world to
entice people to come back calling it a
re-release so that they could beat
avatars box office I think they're a
little bit closer now but I have not
checked the box office since I post my
last video there was a Stan Lee tribute
then there was a Hulk post-credit scene
of an unfinished deleted scene I've
already done a video about that I'll
link it at the end of this then there
was a special spider-man scene setting
up spider-man far from home so we'll
break that down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos is gonna be crazy
in the next couple of weeks between
spider-man far from home in Comic Con
with their big Marvel phase 4 schedule
we're all expecting a couple really big
surprises we're doing a new IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
spider-man moment on the video so during
this Avengers endgame post-credit scene
there was a dip to black after they did
the big Hulk deleted scene that said and
one more thing
then the camera fades in on Nick Fury
and Maria hill driving past a monument
on their way to I extinct oak Mexico to
investigate this reported attack there's
been a disaster so obviously Nick Fury
is coming in to check out what the
hell's going on
this time it's supposed to be the
Sandman one they drive past this local
monument there's a couple reasons why
they work in religious iconography into
films like this one to foreshadow some
of the themes of what's going to happen
in the next scene and wink at the
overall general theme of the movie and
to because when they depict foreign
cities they usually get tax breaks for
layering a little bit of tourism
highlights just to entice people to come
visit that place after they see the
movie like we'll give you some of your
money back if you make our city look
awesome so more people want to come here
and spend their money on us this might
be the Virgin Mary but it's kind of hard
to tell Catholicism is the dominant
religion of Mexico so most of the famous
religious monuments are Catholic within
the Christian religion the Virgin Mary
gave birth to Jesus who is heralded as
the savior of mankind the themes of the
movie in general are all about who's
going to be the next savior of the world
now the Ironman is dead an initially
spider-man is
that this new Mysterio person who says
he's from another world is going to be
that savior so they're kind of using
this metaphor to make a joke about
Mysterio during the movie being the
quote-unquote rebirth of Iron Man at
least that's how he's presenting himself
and as you see from Peter's classmates
during the other trailer everybody on
the news is completely eating it up
this guy's like Thor and Iron Man all
rolled into one you notice they're
driving an Audi because outtie is
sponsoring the movie that's why you see
Nick Fury driving the e-tron and some of
the other trailers and there's outies
all over the place in all the big action
scenes like on this Tower London Bridge
fight you probably noticed during the
Avengers infinity war post-credits
seemed they were driving an Infiniti
brand car maybe that's just the producer
sense of humor driving an Infiniti
during Avengers infinity war the camera
pans out wide as they drive into town
it's been utterly destroyed by the
supposed Sandman elemental creature you
see some of the religious monuments that
have almost been torn down they drive
into the center of town Maria Hill
starts questioning why they're there
investigating this you notice the number
78 on a bucket behind them that's an
Easter Egg for the 1978 amazing
spider-man television series
[Music]
one of the alternate titles for that
series too was spider-man strikes back
because it was around 1978 everybody was
trying to copy the Star Wars franchise
because it was so popular and Empire
Strikes Back was about to come out the
show actually aired during the late 70s
for just a couple of seasons and it was
Nicholas Hammond playing Peter Parker
spider-man the whole idea of the series
though was that because they didn't have
a budget for a really big action scenes
like you would see in a comic book is
that it was spider-man being more
friendly neighborhood spider-man
tackling real world problems taking a
more realistic route instead of doing
really crazy big super villains so his
very mundane version of spider-man Maria
Hill gets out of the car and says Nick
this was a tragedy but it's not why
we're here
what are we fighting the weather now
because she thinks that it was just a
rogue cyclone Nick Fury replies the
locals say the cyclone had a face Maria
Hill says people see things when they're
under stress okay that doesn't mean that
this is the start of some other big
world ending event referencing the
events of Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame with all the Infinity
Gauntlet snaps which during the events
of a spider-man far from home they're
referring to as the blip because people
seemingly blipped out of existence when
Thanos snapped everyone at the end of
Avengers infinity war then they blipped
back all of a sudden when Hulk snapped
everyone back during endgame
I think snapping probably would have
been a much better term for it but maybe
because the fans came up with it they
couldn't use it in the movie because of
attribution or some weird issue like
that so for whatever reason they're just
calling the snap the blip they walk past
a car here if you look on the license
plate
it reads 463 which is the date of the
first appearance of Sandman an amazing
spider-man number four it was September
1963 all the elementals have Easter eggs
like this any time they show up there's
always a license plate or a number
nearby on something showing the date of
their first appearance in the comics so
keep your eyes peeled when you go to see
spider-man far from home this week
anytime there's a date in the background
like the 78 on the bucket behind them
here there's a number on a wall on a
boat on a license plate it's usually a
reference or an Easter Egg to some
big spider-man comic book moment during
amazing spider-man or amazing fantasy or
anytime spider-man has popped up in a
really big story
all the sudden Mysterio appears in a
green cloud of smoke as if he's
seemingly teleported in they raised
their guns and he says who are you
because they haven't met each other yet
kind of out of breath as if he's coming
from another battle and this is taking a
lot of effort he wants to make it seem
like he's putting a lot into this when
all of a sudden the Sandman elemental
rises up behind them roars they spin
around turned their guns on it then the
camera pans back to Mysterio who says
you don't want any part of this and just
lets loose his green energy attack that
you've been seeing in all the trailers
so this is supposed to be the first time
that Nick Fury meets Mysterio so he's
never heard of him before this he has no
idea who he is like who the hell is this
dude that's fighting this giant
elemental creature later Mysterio gives
him his version of an explainer speech
for how the elementals work where they
come from when he's talking about the
multiverse this is the extended clip of
that that they've already released
online they were born in stable orbits
within black holes creatures forms from
the primary elements air water fire
earth the science division had a
technical name we just called them
elementals versions of them exists
across our mythologies turns out the
myths are real like Thor Bora was a myth
and now I study him in my physics class
these myths of threats they first
materialized on my earth many years ago
I was part of the last battalion life
trying to stop them all we did was delay
the inevitable
the elementals are here now attacking
the same coordinates our satellites
confirm it I mean I'm just a friendly
neighborhood spider-man sir [ __ ] please
you've been to space spider-man is
eating that up like candy that's the
story that Mysterio is giving them at
least at the beginning of the movie so
I'll talk more about what's going on
with this during the film what concepts
it sets up the Easter eggs the
post-credits scene in how it sets up the
future of spider-man in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in the future of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in general
during Marvel phase four because this is
technically the bookend to Marvel phase
3 and then Marvel phase 4 will
officially begin in the next film that
comes which will be Black Widow next
spring so there's a lot of really big
things that they do at the end of the
film
make sure you stay through
end of the credits is spider-man far
from home very important post credits
scenes I'll do videos for those next
week so no worries but they are
positioning spider-man to be one of the
most central figures in the next several
years in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
sort of the same way that he was the
face of Marvel Comics brand for a long
time Kevin Feige has quietly been doing
this ever since Spiderman came into the
MCU in all of his early interviews
before spider-man homecoming was getting
ready to come out he was going on and on
about how spider-man was the most
important Marvel character ever
spider-man is the biggest Marvel
character he is the jewel in the crown
such an amazing icon he is a very
different type of hero because he is
quite simply the greatest superhero of
all time so you look at things like that
and how important spider-man was to the
brand of Marvel Comics and how important
he is to Kevin Feige plans for the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and it's gonna get really really crazy
really fast I'm sure you all have a lot
of really big questions about what's
going on in the next couple of years so
leave them all in the comments and I'll
try to add them to the videos that I'm
making in the next week it was a really
big Avengers endgame Comic Con panel
with Captain America a couple of the
other characters where they talk about
new deleted scenes and stuff that was
cut out it was really cool I'll cut that
way down to just the best moments and
then post that tomorrow so should be
sometime on Monday my spider-man far
from home post credit scene video in
Easter eggs will start posting on
Tuesday and Wednesday so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see those videos when I post them
I'll name a giveaway winner when I post
that next video click here for that Houk
avengers endgame post credit scene in
the special stanley tribute scene and
click here for my non-spoilery
spider-man far from home movie review
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you